ma mère c'est une vraie maman
[Musique]
c'est vrai que je dois tout à ma mère
parce que elle a toujours su passer le
temps qu'il fallait pour moi c'est je
veux pas que mon fils devienne comme ça
c'est pas possible il peut pas grandir
dans ce milieu je veux que ce soit
quelqu'un de de faire en sorte qu'il
soit le plus stable possible qui soit
bien dansé pour tout ça et tout ça ça
crée des moments d'insécurité pour un
enfant et je veux pas que mon fils
grandisse dans dans cette atmosphère là
et je pense que David avait besoin
d'être à l'écart de la turbulence de nos
vies
j'ai toujours voulu recréer
un lieu enfin trouvé un lieu qui
pourrait abriter notre famille notre
addition et justement le conflit était
une protection et elle est devenue le
havre de paix la maison du bonheur pour
nos enfants c'était un peu le lieu que
tout le monde aimait la maison d'automne
emporte le vent
et tout ce que tu
énorme c'est un endroit safe quoi c'est
aussi une bulle de compression en fait
cette maison du bonheur un peu Pirée mon
cousin moi j'avais mon j'avais mon frère
de cœur qui était et de son aussi on a
passé notre enfant côté un trépie qu'on
avait un peu casse-cou avec
nos vélos on faisait des tremplins ont
sauté on faisait un peu les comptes ça
c'était
ouais un peu le paradis on va dire on va
dire ça comme ça et puis pour moi
c'était un endroit sûr
il était solitaire du fait qu'il était
enfant unique et la prunelle de mes yeux
et donc donc il s'occupait lui-même puis
la musique était vraiment
prépondérante et le tenait sa tête son
cœur dans ma famille mon père mon
grand-père mon frère était tous des
musiciens on écoutait beaucoup de
musique
[Musique]
mon oncle trompettiste de jazz
musicien de jazz je lui ressemble
beaucoup à mon oncle d'une certaine
façon dans l'approche à la musique je
pense c'est un passionné qui est très
très talentueux dans son domaine et
c'est surtout quelqu'un qui aimait
mettre sa touche personnelle et aider en
fait
des gens avec qui bossaient mais il
était très très discret j'étais dans son
monde et c'est vrai que
c'était la première image d'homme que
David a eu avec mon papa mais mon papa
il est il est mort malheureusement
quand David avait deux trois ans trois
ans ou en perm maternelle par exemple
c'est un fou ce mec qui fait il se
désert incroyable dans dans plusieurs
domaines artistiques dans la sculpture
dans la peinture et on a tous hérité
dans la famille de quelque chose
d'artistique
[Musique]